♪ ♪ ♪
- Au grand écran, il était
à la fois le sédurrr
irrésistible et l'amant
tourmenté. Jean-Louis
Trintignant rtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrs
grands films du cinéma français.
MICHELLOLOLOMBE, critique cinéma
- Jean-Louis Trintignant n'était
pas un grand acteur, c'étaitun .
HELEN FARADJI, critique cinéma-t
un moment de grande émotion.
- Juliette, veux-tu être
- Cet acteur timide à la voix
en 1956 avec le film "Et Dieu
créa la femme" de Roger Vadim,
où il donnait la réplique à
Brigitte Bardot. Les grands
rôles de sont succédé, avec
et une femme" de Claude Lelouch.
En 196rérérérérérérérérérérérérs
pour le "Z" de Costa Gavras.
v v veux des preuves! Il n'y
a qu'un communiste pour dire ou
penser ce genre de phrase!
FRANÇOIS LÉVESQ
- C'est une suite de films
comme ça, de gs s s films,
de chefs-d'oeuvre qui sont
associés à son nom, à son grain
de voix nénénénénénénénénénénénl
est en deuil aujourd'hui.
Jean-Louis Trintignant a joué
dans près de 130 films, ensss
de cumuler les rôles au théâtre.
- C'est de tous les acteurs
français le plus italijojojojojé
une trentaine de fois dans
les films italiens.
Il était très ami, par exemple,
On l'a vu dans "La terrasse",
un grandm,m,m, mais on l'a vu
dans "Le conformiste" aussi,
"Le conformiste" de Bertolucci.
- À la foisédédédien et pilote
automobile, la vie personnelle
de Jean-Louis Trintignant a été
marqué
Marie tititignant, tuée en 2003
par le musicien Bertrand Cantat.
- C'est quelqu'un qui a toujours
ét
qui s'est pas du tout livré dans
sur ces tragédies-là, mais qui,
je pense, à utiliser l'art,
en particulier le théâtre,dedede
se raccrocher à quelque chose
de plus lumineuxs s s la vie.
- Que ce soit dans le film
"Rouge" sorti en 1994 ou
dans "Amour", Palme d'or
à Cannes en 2012, Jean-Louis
Trintignant aura brillé jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie.
♪ ♪ ouououououououououououououos
ses grands rôles, inoubliables.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouim
Radio-Canada, Montréal.